for the second time in less than a month
video shows Baltimore police officers
allegedly planting evidence newly
released body camera footage apparently
shows officers placing drugs in a car
the alleged incident happened during an
arrest in November officers were
searching the car after witnessing what
they said looked like a drug deal Jeff
the gas is in Washington with what a
defense lawyer says the cameras captured
Jeff good morning good morning the
officers are accused of manufacturing
evidence and the public defender's
office says that all you have to really
do is look at the police body camera
video to see it which a big step up what
do you stop - body cameras were rolling
during a traffic stop last November the
video shows Baltimore police officers
searching a car for drugs as one of the
suspects is arrested he accuses the
officers of harassing him for days you
cook that's what you did according to
the public defender's office the
officers found nothing in the car until
turning their body cameras off when the
cameras came back on an officer is seen
squatting by the driver's side of the
suspects car apparently unaware that
he's being recorded
he then stands up and steps back about
30 seconds pass another officer
approaches the car that officer then
squats down and pulls out a bag of drugs
frankly when it's your word against the
police it's a it's quite an uphill climb
for a lot of people in Baltimore City
and attorney Joshua Inslee says the
footage absolves his clients shimira
collins who was facing drug charges
after the incident she didn't think
anybody would believe her but you know
the cameras were all wrong one and she
ended up being vindicated the Baltimore
Police said in a statement any time an
allegation of misconduct is made against
an officer they take it seriously and
investigated fully this is the second
time in recent weeks Baltimore officers
have been accused of planting evidence
body camera footage released about two
weeks ago involving different Baltimore
police officers allegedly shows drugs
being planted in a backyard the
investigation into that incident is on
going the case against Inslee's client
has also been dismissed but he says this
is not the end of their legal fight she
lives in the city she doesn't want any
trouble between her and the police but
she feels like you know but she feels
like she had drugs playing it on her and
she definitely wants justice with these
recent cases coming to light the concern
is that this is more of a common
occurrence than originally thought last
night Baltimore Police Commissioner
Kevin Davis sent a memo to officers
reminding them that they are required to
activate their body cameras when
responding to calls and searching for
evidence and they are required to keep
those body cameras on Charlie
yep the guys in Washington Jeff thanks